let's talk about this other idea that
you had mention last time so uber driver
revenue streams total revenue streams
and lyft you know I I'm neither we don't
discriminate yeah no I love them both
right whatever's cheaper but for me I
try to think a lot about their are
resting assets that are currently
sitting idle right and so how can you
what's a resting asset a resting asset
is something like how uber a scale
because they have drivers that are
sitting out there for themselves or
people just driving around that want to
make extra income so for uber for
instance how can we take that a step
further you have people that are online
with uber that are currently waiting for
rides and they have when they get
someone in their car they have a captive
audience there's been a handful of
startups that if somewhat helped
alleviate this because the big thing
that has come out a lot lately
especially with some of the new
regulations coming in is that uber and
lyft drivers driving full-time are
making far less than minimum wage right
like far less when you account for all
the expenses and the idle times I think
we had the stat here what does it say
the average pay per hour in America for
full time is 855 to 1177 on uber on uber
yeah or all right yeah right yeah in
America the average full-time for a
driver full-year 36 525 a year right
that's that's that's minimum wage right
and so I think it's no one they're not
gonna stop driving over they're not
gonna stop driving left but how can you
take something like a uber or lyft
driver who for between 7 and 30 minutes
has a captive audience right so how do
you give them a 3 dollar an hour raise
how do you help them make more money so
people have tried this currently
interactive media I think we there's a
octopus interactive has done this
everyone's seen it it's in all cabs in
New York it's in a handful of uber
screen on the back type thing you play a
game yeah it's not targeted so you and
me are getting in there and I guarantee
you if we sat in there right now we're
gonna get served personal injury call me
if you've been hurt in an accident right
has nothing to do with that right okay
but that's one way one way another one
that I actually liked was cargo it just
helps them sell things right snack
little snack bar exactly but to me what
I've been thinking a lot about is how do
you which is really big obviously the
last handful of years which is really
take
office personalization so if you think
about if you're able to truly partner
with uber think about the type of
information they have on you as a rider
how old you are your frequent places
that you're living even the micro
targeting the geolocation of where you
are we can make a lot of assumptions
about you we could you know song we
could probably assume your your well off
maybe we can know that you have family
or you're currently doing a lot of pools
or luxury and so we can start to build a
profile around you and with that type of
information through like the stereo for
instance how could we serve you very
targeted direct ads right so advertising
is one the one that I am really
interested in I have a little bit of
background in is in the music space and
so for me it's like okay a music label
wants to get their new artist someone
that they've invested in in front of the
right consumer especially in that first
week where they want songs to hit that
kind of viral effect right and so if you
were able to build a music platform to
partner with labels and over to actually
serve direct music towards a very
targeted audience and you could make
money by playing that song right I think
it'd be a great business yeah that's
pretty interesting cuz I don't know how
many rides there are per day but there's
millions of rides per day and so those
are all sort of audio impressions yeah
you could use and I think if you played
ads out loud that would be sort of
obnoxious but if you're playing awesome
new music you know that could be that
could be really interesting where it's
sort of non-invasive it's actually you
know sort of behind the scenes yeah you
don't even have to tell the writer hey
this is you know you're listening to
this because of X it's just there's what
the driver has on yeah and the driver
gets paid to have their radio on exactly
specifically into a certain station a
lot hooked into their app cuz a lot of
the time either you're telling them what
to change too or they're putting on
something you don't like right and so
now this is okay we think we understand
you as an individual so we're gonna try
to serve you music that you like right
and I'm helping the driver make more
money right yeah I like this idea a lot
I think this is cool
Firefly put the big kind of thing on the
top of the Ebers is that is it Firefly
that raised last week or was it the
other one so Firefly raised prior and it
may have raised again I don't know if
they raised a huge round prior and like
twenty thirty million bucks and then I
believe lyft announced that they were
doing this themselves so one of the
ride-sharing companies announced that
they're doing this themselves which is
gonna be now
to see what happens with that but I like
the idea I also just generally like the
underlying reason this was interesting
to you which was something's changed so
what's changed okay well now we have
this fleet of drivers that are all
connected using these apps that are on
the road all the time that's new
inventory we could do something with new
opportunity that we could do something
with and the second thing was hey the
wages have gone down from making $25 an
hour to $10 an hour they're gonna be
very receptive to ways that they can get
their earnings back up because they're
being advertised to that hey you're
making 25 bucks an hour yeah but that's
not your true rate when you take into
account everything and if you find a way
to make the drivers more money even I I
bet you I'm just gonna make an
assumption here that if uber doesn't get
a cut but they're keeping more drivers
on the road that they will leave you
alone yeah they will love you if I find
any way to make drivers work exclusively
like I think cargo is an exclusive
partnership with uber right and so if
you can help just them like their their
driver retention yeah I I think could
really take off yeah I like that idea
[Music]
you